Brazil is on the rise to to power
of political and economic
transformations both of them are very
linked the political transformation
began at first and the economic
transformation came along I think the
political transformation is the one that
led to the economic transformation and
this is a process that I would say it's
been taking the last 20 years
I think there is a price to be paid for
a rapid economic growth especially when
you think it came easily and because it
never does
and if you spend the results of economic
rise very rapidly
you also don't save for the future what
I want to say is that when you have a
very fast rise you don't pay attention
to one of the most important things
which is education
versus reality I think one of the myths
about Brazil is that we have been in a
very solid path and I don't think we are
yet in a very solid path a lot of things
have to be done in Brazil a lot of
reforms otherwise we are not going to be
keeping on that track and sometimes
Brazil is thought about as a country
that has flourished has thrived and it's
it found its own way and I think we have
a lot of work in that sense yet
I think the Olympic Games will play a
pretty significant role to Brazil's rise
to power not only because it's a it's a
window to the world but as an investment
and infrastructure which means a lot in
Brazil because our infrastructure is
still very precarious and in a way that
Brazilians are gonna see themselves in
the world and I think that's important
for a country that's been pretty closed
in itself